gonna take a question from one of the
private Facebook groups where I do
various experiments and this question is
from Christian B while reading and
living stoicism how do you avoid
spending too much time thinking about
the inevitability of death and how do
you harness it to empower you rather
than scare or overwhelm you so let's
begin with a definition of terms
stoicism or stoic philosophy very simply
and this is going to be simplified for
any academics out there who want to poke
holes in it is a philosophical system
that focuses on separating the things
you can control from the things you
cannot control and then instills in your
daily practice habits and exercises such
that you can focus as much of your
energy as possible on things you can
control
part of stoicism is meditating on death
certain inevitabilities and finding
freedom in that instead of overwhelm
alright that sounds very nice and
theoretical and conceptual what does
that mean in practice I spend an amount
of time that might seem ridiculous
reminding myself of death and this
sounds morbid but it is very valuable to
me because it emphasizes the
impermanence and the short duration of
life that we have which gives me a sense
of urgency to pursue the things that are
important it gives me a sense of urgency
in having the uncomfortable
conversations that are so important in
life that can define the next chapters
of your life that can change your life
and without a sense of urgency when you
sort of cover your eyes and ears to not
think about death it is easy to push
things off - tomorrow - tomorrow -
tomorrow until you die and it's too late
and you would have benefited from asking
those uncomfortable questions taking
those uncomfortable actions far sooner
so I have
instance a memento mori coin made by a
friend of mine an author Ryan holiday
well known for his writing on stoicism
which acts as a visual reminder I have
different quotes that are laser etched
on to driftwood that also serve this
purpose and for that reason Christian I
I don't try to avoid spending too much
time thinking about the inevitability of
death and the way that at least I find
it empowering instead of overwhelming is
to recognize a it's outside of your
control be it happens to everyone and
see you can control in a sense or hone
your perception of death and view it as
a catalyzing help as opposed to an
overwhelming sadness and one practice
that might seem unusual that I have
found very valuable and this harkens
back to an anecdote or maybe an allegory
of sorts that I was told by Tara brach
famous meditation teacher and that is a
famous sage once said the only question
worth asking is what are you unwilling
to feel so as you think about death and
how you relate to death you may also
think about how you relate to other
emotions you don't want to feel from me
particularly with a history of
depression up until say five years ago
where I have not had any major
depressive episodes in the last five
years and then I think in part what I'm
going to describe has been very helpful
for staving off depression I optimized
for positive positive positive positive
meaning I wanted as many moments in my
day to be purely positive as possible I
did not want to feel sad I did not want
to feel tired I did not want to feel
angry so on and so forth those emotions
are going surface and when you have
labeled them as bad and try to refuse
them with as much mental willpower and
emotional power as possible
what you resist tends to persist and
those things have an outsized impact on
your life negative impact conversely if
you use and here's the practice say
minor-key music which I had not used
until a few years ago didn't listen to
minor-key music and then just look up
minor key piano music to get a taste for
what this sounds like it instills
melancholy it has a sad sound to it and
I've I've begun listening to music that
evokes that type of feeling deliberately
because at the end of listening to this
music for say 5 to 10 minutes and then
you play another track that has a more
upbeat feeling to it say a lot of bossa
nova from Brazil you realize that the
sadness much like excitement is
transient and that your psyche is porous
in that sense the excitement flows into
you and then it flows out of you not
literally but of course that is the
subjective experience and that's also
true of sadness which a lot of us try to
avoid and when you realize how transient
that is and how you can turn it on and
turn it off with cues in your
environment it becomes less intimidating
it becomes less overwhelming you can use
films in the same way watching films
that are scary sad depressive whatever
it might be and then contrasting that
with something that is on the opposite
end of the spectrum that is a practice
in other words seeking out artistic cues
that catalyze emotions historically have
tried to avoid that transcends the
practice itself and helps you to relate
differently to things like death because
most likely what you fear or what you
find abhorrent is not so much death
itself but the way that you're
emotionally relating to the concept or
definition of death I know that sounds
very very abstract but that is one way
that I've approached this in controlled
legal settings I will also say that
transcendent psychedelic experiences can
greatly remove a fear of death I think
that relates to some of the
phenomenology aka subjective reports of
a feeling of fusing with source
consciousness but we're gonna get off
into crazy town talk real fast if we
continue with discussing that particular
aspect of my own personal journey
nonetheless in legal safe supervised
settings that is also a tool in the
toolkit it can be an overused tool in
the toolkit but nonetheless it is it is
one tool
similarly there are questions you can
ask that I think show you or showcase
the value of keeping death in mind such
as one question and I'm gonna paraphrase
this this is from Mooney Ali who was in
tribal mentors and I believe the
question I asked him was what do you do
when you feel scattered or overwhelmed
and his response and I apologize if I'm
not getting this completely right but
it's paraphrasing I do use this a lot
when you are experiencing something
simple laying in a warm bed an example
that comes to mind for me is laying in a
hammock watching my dog Molly play with
a stick
when you are on your deathbed how much
would you pay or even 20 years from now
how much would you pay to relive this
experience right now and very often that
number gets quite high maybe it's
something that you physically might not
be able to do 30 years from now 40 years
from now I was just skiing a few days
ago and had a wonderful experience with
two of my closest friends what would I
pay 40 years from now to have that day
back and experience that and think about
it don't throw away that question and
make up a number really think about what
you might spend and I think that
highlights the value of experience
relative to this decay that we all
experience pass a certain
client on our descent to death and those
are a few of the ways that I try to
harness mortality to empower and enrich
my life as opposed to disabling or
distracting if that makes sense so those
are a few tips few recommendations that
have been deeply helpful to me and if
you'd like to learn more about stoicism
then I would suggest you google Tao of
Seneca ta o of Seneca Seneca being one
of the foremost writers or best-known
writers as it relates to stoic
philosophy I put together three large
PDFs that are available for free with
the original artwork and all sorts of
fun stuff that dig deeper into the
practical applications of stoic
philosophy
you